what are you putting in your body dead
carcass pain suffering fear can I have
all of my vegans go into that pool of
light and my non-vegans in that pool
away first statement taste plays a big
factor in my eating choices yeah I mean
that's a huge thing for me I think it's
one of my weaknesses actually like
butter salt it's one of my weaknesses I
love food actually deepened when I
became vegan I don't think I appreciated
it as much as I did before I was vegan
my name is Aubrey Davis and I have been
vegetarian for 24 years and a vegan for
13 years I believe that humans are the
top of the food chain
is a human at the same level of
equivalence is like a fish right there's
probably a big reason why I'm not vegan
anymore right is I didn't I could I
didn't see that I had to see myself I
don't moral equivalent of a fish and it
gets into moral questions like you know
why should we have a pet that's a dog
rather than eat the dog and I think the
most important question is why should I
love my neighbor rather than eat my
neighbor my name is Steve Michele ski I
was a vegan for a year I was vegetarian
for two years I'm a meat-eater now I've
been so for over five years like I don't
even see like what is like a food chain
you know I'm saying that's just some
contract some guy made and put a little
diagram and put us the human beings on
the top so I don't leave the question of
whether we're at the top I think it's a
question of what do you do with that if
you have a more conscious energy than an
animal what do you do with that power do
you choose to take a life or do you
choose to live in love I put a lot of
thought into my meals the way I support
my body and my health is extremely
important I don't find that I can
function at my best either healthy
productive emotionally stable or
intellectually capable unless I have a
lot of proper nutrients in my diet six
years ago I became vegan because I got
sick I started to realize that my health
was directly attached to what I ate
since then my friends and family have
supported me to feeling better and I'm
better than I once before I got sick I
don't really like cook or anything so I
don't really put too much thought into
what I eat I guess I live a fast paced
kind of like I'm working late night so
I'm waking up early so sometimes it's
easier to grab this quick process
sandwich or I wish I planned my meals
out more I think I would be a lot I
would feel a lot better I think it's
really powerful no matter what you're
eating to put your intentions into
whether it's prayer invocation and
there's such great power and presence
versus just like scarfing something down
but like can I just really be present
with this meal take my time and chew it
slowly so that's the first night
resonate with and what I choose to do I
would kill an animal
I think there'd be tons of context where
I'd kill an animal like if if a Lions
gonna go kill a baby I'd probably kill
an animal
I'd kill an animal to save a human life
and I get the vegans probably wouldn't
do that if I could do something to
prevent killing them besides eating them
like if I was protecting myself and we
had to we had it like a something that
we could do to get that animal away I
would definitely try to not kill it I
mean Ivy comes down to you with the
animal you killing the animal I would I
would give up their life for the fish
why is it always the case when talking
about would I kill an animal like
exactly if you were lions running around
downtown LA when I was in the hiking
there's there's mountain lions that
coming and kill people you've known that
right that's an Orange County that's not
that's not in the jungle in Africa it's
Orange County mountain lions have killed
hikers kids just let them know let the
yes I we're hiking in the mountains and
there's a mountain lion I have to be
aware the fact that I'm in mountain lion
territory and be like I'm okay with the
risk because to be honest I'm not hiking
with a gun I have no way to defend my
friend you don't hike with a hiking pole
I mean I can pull against a mountain
lion I don't think you're I just I just
want to say like even if I did and even
if my attempt were to be successful I
would feel awful having killed the
mountain lion what way your feelings or
your foundation than for your beliefs
100% are human beings animals yes yes
sure would you kill another human being
to save another human being yes what
makes one person more viable to another
is it your relationship to that person
it would yeah it would probably be so if
for example I raised an animal in the
wild it's like an animal I've built a
relationship with and that animal now
threatens the life of a human being but
I don't know but I've known an animal
its entire life what makes killing that
animal as just cause okay as opposed to
saving that life
I have a live a longer relationship with
that animal why would I kill the animal
before I'd save that person it's not
relationship you kill them a person / an
animal it's because I believe human
beings are animals now I see humans at a
different level but maybe a value fish
at the same levels person I have we see
it very different I do it costs more
than it should to eat healthy it's more
expensive to eat healthy I don't think
it's too expensive farmers market is
something that I'm trying to frequent
more but sometimes you know you can go
spend twenty dollars here and definitely
not get as much I definitely want to see
that you know maybe that'll encourage
people to eat a little healthier if you
can go grab that fresh fruit those fresh
veggies for five ten bucks you know I
think our culture as a society is just
in great towards like the fast food
culture and which is cheap and
accessible but now I think we have more
of established like medical bases on
what's healthy and what's not healthy
and to get that content and to have it
be tasty as well
is is expensive I'm running in it does
not cost more money to be vegan that is
a myth it takes planning yes the
convenience is less can you grab a
hamburger at McDonalds for sure for 99
cents but how much lentils can you buy
the issue is capitalism like that is
what is keeping us where we are it's not
that humans are smarter and they're
gonna come up with this technology the
technology exists it is there we can
feed so many people it is capitalism and
factory farming and most these companies
that are selling us products that are
like shitty food they don't give a [ __ ]
about you at all period someone sitting
on the island somewhere
oh yeah like just stacking bread and
then probably fast food eating really
healthy food
that [ __ ] you go to certain
neighborhoods certain areas you don't
see the same fast-food you don't see the
same restaurant and it's all for a
reason they know I mean yeah that's a
good point it's like they don't have
why's there are many health food stores
in the hood like my pant like get an
option Weiser Lucas is everywhere and
it's true it's like gift when you break
it down there's like malicious intent to
D harmonize and like lower the vibration
of certain people in certain areas and
it's like that's a part of it too it's
like what am i contributing to true I'll
say this you know when I was 11 years
old my father passed away from his
second heart attack he was diabetic he
was pissing out of a2 by Washington
deteriorate my youngest here's my life
for like years and years just to tr-8
taking pharmaceutical drugs and just
kind of basically dying slowly because
of what he chose the 8th to me I'd
rather spend an extra dollar
I need organic or something healthy now
and live longer than try to cut corners
when you know now instead of later my
mom would same thing she died she she
was eating buckets of ice cream when she
passed away she died at 49 years old Wow
now choose now the more education that
we can put out there just like stuff
like this is beautiful that's what I was
most anxious about is learning more of
what I'm trying to step into I don't
know if I'll ever give up chicken I'm
just gonna be honest with you I don't
know I want to eat a lot cleaner chicken
do you guys have like cheat days ever
I am vegan 100% at the frontline ethical
reasons always always always and that's
why I don't think in 24 years I've ever
gone back it was hard to try new things
things I didn't like found tons of vegan
food that was like oh god [ __ ] you
people here and then simultaneously
realizing that there was options you
know there's always choices and it's
always choices we make like you said you
may never give up meat fully but it's
like you're making a choice or at least
thinking for yourself and making a
decision and like that's all you can ask
people to do is think for themselves
I really appreciate each and every one
of y'all I think
so really appreciate y'all thank you for
coming out what's up guys I am Amari and
I am Jason and am I've got a question
for you you have a question for me what
do you like about little Rhonda what I
like about middle ground is seeing
people come together and like realize
that their labels are not the whole sum
of their experience like take it off
take it off the labels realizing there's
so much more than their labels that's
right I love that all right well tell us
in the comments below why you love
middle ground and if you've been a label
that you want to take off and throw in
the ground tell us that as well we love
you guys as always please subscribe hit
that like button I'll see you next time